syrian unions
president julius mardabio says the
violence was premeditated and designed
to topple his government
he calls the protesters insurrectionists
the full force of the law
will be brought to bear on all those
persons who attacked and killed police
officers
they
their sponsors and their collaborators
will not go unpunished
there will also be a full investigation
into the death of ordinary citizens who
lost their lives in this senseless
violence incited by those unknown
persons
the protests are some of the most
violent cerelian has seen in peacetime
the government says the opposition is to
blame
but the opposition rejects that
accusation they say the government's bad
economic policies are responsible
it's been four years since they came to
power they haven't done anything to move
the needle in the right direction so
that's not an excuse
many businesses have remained shut
as security forces patrol the streets
a 12-hour curfew is still in force
across the country
sierra leone like most african countries
heavily rely on imports and because of
its current supply challenges
the country is also suffering from
inflation with more than half the
population living below the poverty line
people here finding it increasingly
difficult to afford even the basics like
food
the protests come 10 months before the
country's general elections there are
real concerns here that the election
process could be marred by the violence
seen in the past few days mohammed idris
al jazeera freetown serra dion